ask the prime minister to make a
statement on the replacement of the
chancellor of its Checker during the
current economic situation
with apologies with apologies to the
leader of the opposition and the house
the piano is detained on urgent business
[Applause]
and they will they will have to make due
I must hear the answer of why the prime
minister's not here
I'm afraid you'll have to make do with
me Mr Speaker the the Prime Minister has
taken the decision to point my right
honorable friend the member for
Southwest Surrey one of the longest
serving and most experienced
parliamentarians as her Chancellor
[Music]
their overriding priority is to restore
Financial stability in the face of
volatile Global conditions we will take
whatever tough decisions are necessary
and have made changes to the great plan
which the chancellor
which the chancellor is waiting to
update the house on as soon as this
urgent question finishes
summer
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you to
the right honorable member for
Portsmouth North for answering the
question put to the Prime Minister I
guess under this Tory government
everybody gets to be prime minister for
15 minutes
true
an economic crisis made in Downing
Street because they've lost all
credibility government borrowing costs
absurd mortgage rates have ballooned
markets need reassuring and there is
long-term damage that can't be undone
once you've crashed the car at 100 miles
an hour you've damaged it for good and
you're going to be paying much more on
your insurance for years to come and
it's working people who will pay left
wondering if they can afford to stay in
their homes if their hopes of owning a
home haven't already been crushed yeah
so now it's time for leaders to lead but
where is the prime minister
[Applause]
hiding away dodging questions scared of
our own shadow the laid is not for
turning up
now it's time to be honest about the
mistakes they made yeah but what does
the Prime Minister say my vision is
right my mission remains I sack my
Chancellor but I can't tell you why
and now is a time for consistent
messaging but what do we get a prime
minister saying absolutely no spending
reductions a Chancellor saying there
will be cuts a prime minister saying
she's in charge a chancellor who thinks
he's the CEO and she's just the chair
yeah yeah
it needs when all the government offers
is grotesque chaos how can Britain get
the stability it needs when instead of
leadership we have this utter vacuum
yeah how can Britain get the stability
it needs when the Prime Minister has no
mandate from her party and no mandate
from the country
yeah
all right
thank you Mr Speaker let me start by
saying I'm quite quietly confident that
the leader of the opposition will not
have his 15 minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with with regards with regard to
questions raised on economic policy I
will defer to the chancellor honorable
members honorable members will want time
to question him fully and hear the
detail I do not wish to eat into that
time our constituents will want to hear
about the issues facing them their bills
mortgages benefits and their businesses
so I had wondered just what else the
leader of the opposition wished to
discuss in this uq that would delay such
an important statement in his in his
urgent question he paints a contrast so
let me paint one too
the decision taken by our prime minister
would have been a very tough one
politically
[Music]
personally
she has taken it and she has done so
she has done so because it is manifestly
in the National interest that she did
she did not hesitate to do so because
her focus is on the well-being of every
one of our citizens
it was the right thing to do and whether
you agree with it or not it took courage
to do it
Trust
[Applause]
in contrast what the right honorable
gentleman has done today
at this most serious moment took no
courage or judgment or regard to the
National interest
[Applause]
three years ago Mr Speaker
three years ago when this Parliament was
paralyzed by brexit a general election
would have been in the National interest
and he blocked it
[Applause]
today when the country needs some
stability and
Urgent legislation to put through cost
of living measures and while we are in
the middle of an economic War leveled at
every school and Hospital in this
country he now calls for one and weeks
of disruption and delay
we will take no lectures from The
Honorable Gentleman on working in the
National interest
[Applause]
I could point to his frustration of us
leaving the EU and campaigning for a
second referendum
to his support for the right honorable
member for Islington North and his
positions on NATO all his arguments
against us leaving lockdown or are
involvement of the EU vaccines agency
all against the national interest
and nor will we take any lectures on
consistency of policy or messaging
[Applause]
gentleman has abandoned every single one
of his pledges during the labor
leadership contest
[Applause]
I think the country also wants to hear
what's being said if I can't hear their
country so can we please listen to
leaders I'm sure it's coming to the end
now there's a house I am Mr Speaker
which is why even
Mr Perkins if you want to go get a cup
of tea I'm more than happy to pay for it
foreign
which is why Mr Speaker even on our
toughest and most disappointing days I
will always be proud to sit on this side
of the house
we will put the national interests first
now let's get on and hear from the
chancellor
first of all I want to hear from the
leader of the House more importance of
Peter bottomless
can I say to my relatable friend
that the leader of the opposition has
reversed most of the things he said to
do if he became leader yeah if you have
a short memory it's only nine months ago
when some of his senior colleagues were
circling say when they could be a better
needed opposition than him yeah and can
I push it to the lead of the house that
when circumstances change it's right for
policy to change and if what's announced
today leads to Allure rate of inflation
a lower cost of borrowing and the
greatest chance this country can get
back to prosperity it's worth doing
[Applause]
well I I agree with the uh father of the
house in what he says um The Honorable
right honorable gentleman opposite has
reversed his position on economic
justice social justice climate change
promoting peace and human rights common
ownership defending migrants rights
strengthening the rights of uh workers
and trade unions right according to
evolution of power wealth and
opportunity equality and effective
opposition to the Tories we don't come
to sap SMP spokesperson Kirsten Oswald
thank you Mr Speaker
today's Scotland's first Minister set
out an optimistic ambitious and credible
economic plan for Scotland's future a
leader who spent over an hour setting
out and answering questions on the
positive case for our country's
Independence it's a very stark contrast
to a prime minister hiding in Downing
Street the Prime Minister terrified to
answer for the mess she has made the
mess which will cause so much harm to
all of our constituents so Mr Speaker
I'm going to keep this short and to the
point can the leader of the House tell
us exactly where on Earth is the prime
minister and if she doesn't even have
the backbone to show up here today is
there really any point in her showing up
here again surely time's up she needs to
go and let the people decide
well I'm glad to hear the first minister
of Scotland made a statement I'm hoping
that shortly the house will be able to
hear from the chances Checker to set out
the government's position I'd be
interested to know if the first
Minister's statement included the tax
dividend to every Scottish household of
being a member of the United Kingdom
really
the facts are that the global economic
conditions that we Face have worse and
now the opposition may not want to
acknowledge that but that is the truth
inflation rates have increased around
the world and in the United States are
now the highest they've been since 1982.
does my right honorable friend agree
that we should always be prepared to
make the policy changes we need in the
best interests of the people that we
represent
I do agree with my right honorable
friend and that is why the Prime
Minister has taken this decision
Dave Andrew
thank you very much Mr Speaker
what we have seen in the last month is
one of the largest humiliations that
this country has ever experienced
and it's directly as a result of the
current prime minister's agenda which
she set out to the tiny sliver of UK
people that voted for her to be the
Prime Minister now the right honorable
lady is is perhaps auditioning to be the
next one along because surely she knows
that this humiliated prime minister
simply cannot last
[Applause]
look this as I said in my opening
remarks this will have been a very
difficult decision for the Prime
Minister and she has taken it because it
is in the National interest and she
should have all of our support in doing
so
thank you Mr Speaker if I was the
financial director of a PLC and I went
to a board and suggested that we cut
um our revenues greatly and we wouldn't
put up a tax an increase next year
the director of the board would look at
me and say well that's good so Peter
what are the spending implications and
how is it going to be funded
and unfortunately for the previous
Chancellor he didn't provide those
answers we had a statement lasting two
and a half hours instead of a budget
which should have been debated for 23 or
24 hours
so would the leader of the House admit
that that's the reason the chancellor
had to do he produced a part budget not
the whole thing
well I thank my honorable friend for his
remarks and I hope that we will soon be
able to hear from the chancellor on
these important matters concerns for
members of this house and also their
constituents Ed David speaker the
previous prime minister
shattered The public's trust in the
government
the current prime minister has trashed
the British economy
meanwhile conservative MPS have sat
there and let it happen
so for the damage and pain they have
caused across our country
will the leader of the House on behalf
of a whole party address the people and
businesses of our great country and
apologize
[Applause]
I thank the right honorable gentleman of
this question we have made this change
for a reason and I understand that
people want people want certainty and
reassurance about their bills their
businesses and their benefits and I am
sorry that the events leading to the
changes today have added to the concerns
about the major volatility that was
already there existing in the economy
that's why we are putting it right today
and what my right honorable friend the
chancellor will be speaking about in his
announcement shortly Richard Grant
speaker the country is waiting to hear
from the chancellor on issues of fiscal
responsibility Market stability and
sustainable growth does my right
honorable friend agree with me that what
this entirely unnecessary debate shows
is that the opposition are putting
politics before the interest of our
constituents
I agree with my honorable friend
completely
that was really bad very much Mr Speaker
the leader of the House said yesterday
that what the country needs is stability
and not a soap opera I agree with her so
can she explain to the house why the
prime minister is still in office when
it's clear to almost everyone including
many of her colleagues behind her today
that she is no longer in power yeah
I think it is incredibly important today
that the chancellor be allowed to set
out the policy changes that is made to
provide answers to this house and the
country and we can restore some
certainty to the growth program that is
what will help stability and I would ask
all honorable members to consider in
their questioning to me how those
questions will help that's Narnia
Stephen Crabb
thank you Mr Speaker
pragmatism dealing with the world as it
is those are traditional strengths of
conservatives in government and the
changes fiscal changes being announced
by the new Chancellor today are entirely
correct does my right honorable friend
agree with me though that the very last
thing that's needed right now the last
thing that mortgage holders need people
to struggling to get on the housing
ladder people weren't paying their fuel
bills the very last thing they need
right now is further political
instability upsetting markets
is right and we also need to put through
legislation to enact some of the
measures that will help with the cost of
living issues people are facing uh we
need time on the floor of this house to
do that and we also need to give the
public some certainty about the future
thank you
turbulence in the markets though and the
reason that the chancellor was replaced
is not just about tax it's about trust
and Trust in the British government
comes from the knowledge that it enjoys
the consent of the British people how
does she think that's going live in the
house I think that the chancellor should
be able to come to the floor of the
house and and outline his policies this
is a serious moment we want to ensure
that the markets are reassured and I
would uh suggest that any question she
has on economic policy are directed to
the chancellor Alberta Cube Mr Speaker
in giving the answer that she did to the
leader of the opposition my right
honorable friend has abundantly
demonstrated to this house what an
enormous asset she is to the government
how to
kind of and can I just ask can I just
ask the right honorable lady
does she agree with me
that any single conservative MP would
make a fantastic Chancellor well above
any socialist or separatist offices
[Applause]
I think in terms of the opposition's
performance I think Larry the cat would
give him a run for their money Sammy
Wilson Mr Speaker
hi my colleagues take no joy in the
difficulties which the government and
the country finds itself in a present
because of course it affects all of our
constituents and we're the leader of the
house not agree with me that for most
people watching this today
they don't want to see political Point
scoring or in-house backstabbing they
want to know how they're going to be
able to afford to pay their mortgages
how are they going to meet their cost of
living and how are they going to make
decisions about their businesses through
the house be right on the gentleman is
absolutely right and uh lovely though I
am I think people want to hear from the
chancellor they want to hear the detail
of the policies that are changing they
want to be able to members will want to
be able to ask them about how that is
going to affect their constituents that
is what we should be focusing on today
John Lubbock
speaker I'm very much welcome the speed
at which the new chancellor has acted
but can the leader of the house and
confirm that the chancellor and all
members of the government will continue
to work with colleagues in the back
bench who's the sure to ensure that we
are able to communicate the great
successes of this conservative
government to all parts of the nation
yeah
well thank you I know no I know the
chancellor wants to work with all
members of this house in the interests
of all of our constituents
um and I hope that there will be uh also
opportunities to talk about our record
in government uh and how we've
transformed this country for the better
since 2010
thank you
The house's response to this urgent
question was quite frankly ridiculous
claiming that the Prime Minister
cowering in some corner somewhere is
courageous it does not take courage to
crash our economy it takes Reckless
arrogance in a disregard for ordinary
people's working lives he does not take
courage to sack her Chancellor after
barely a month it takes
total desperate opportunism so will she
admit that what it will take to restore
our fiscal credibility and the
confidence of the market is a labor
government yeah
the prime minister's actions did take
courage personal courage and it was the
right thing to do in the National
interest I think the right thing to do
in the National interest is let the
chancellor give his statement Duncan
Baker thank you Mr Speaker whether it
was during the pandemic and 450 billion
pounds spent whether it is Ukraine and a
hundred thousand refugees who are now in
our country that our constituents are
looking after or whether it is the
hardship to the energy crisis kind of my
right and we're trying to tell us that
this government will always do what is
necessary to step up to the plate and
help the most vulnerable people in
society across in our country and the
rest of the world
end of the house as I'm sure the
chancellor will say we we are in very
volatile times the the war in Ukraine is
uh it's not just a uh a war against the
people of Ukraine it is an economic war
against other nations too and we will
always do the right thing in those
circumstances let's double
veneer of fiscal responsibility fails to
disguise that imposing more painful
austerity is a political Choice made to
save the absentee prime minister from
the consequences of her ideological
experiment with Welsh government already
facing a shortfall of over 4 billion
pounds over three years and public
services close to buckling further
austerity will try entrench the most
fast wealth inequalities that
characterize this disunited Kingdom will
she admit that now even the pretense of
leveling up is dead
ask the honorable lady to remember that
we have given the largest budget ever to
the devolved administrations but against
the backdrop of coming into government
where there was no money left we still
have managed to hold down fuel Duty
introduce a living wage create a modern
welfare system where people are better
off and got nearly 4 million people into
work
we'll be more
can I share the government's desire to
reduce the tax on working people but of
course we must ensure stability in the
markets because these go hand in hand
and therefore I welcome the Chancellor's
announcement to the markets earlier this
morning so can my right honorable friend
confirm that the government is working
with the obr and others in developing
policy for the upcoming medium term for
school plan well I thank for his remarks
he is absolutely right to stress the
importance of stability and I think that
will be helped by the chance of being
able to make a statement
thank you Mr Speaker the leader of the
House suggests that we should be
grateful that the Prime Minister has
made a difficult decision and I presume
she means grateful that she stuck to it
given the number of u-turns that we've
seen over the life still a couple days
but that's the job making difficult
decisions there are difficult decisions
to be made about what is happening in
Ukraine about the fact that President
Putin has nuclear weapons about the
chaos caused by brexit gang crime the
climate crisis Ebola in Africa and all
we know right now is unless she tells us
otherwise that the prime minister is
cowering under her desk and asking for
it all to go away
isn't it about time she did and let
somebody else who can make decisions in
the British national interests get in
charge instead of the house well the
prime minister is not under a desk
[Applause]
I can assure I can assure the house
I can assure the house
I can assure the house that she is
which with regret she is not here for a
very good reason
but no
but neither has uh has she taken this
decision to win the uh honorable lady's
gratitude she's done it out of a sense
of Duty because she knows what's in the
National interest
thank you Mr Speaker said it will have
been a difficult decision for the Prime
Minister vote uh politically and also
personally because of our loyalty to my
right honorable friend from spellthorne
but it's vital that we provide economic
stability for families and businesses
and constituencies like mine and across
the country and we've already seen that
this morning from the chancellor so does
she agree with me that it's high time
that this house heard from the
chancellor about how we are going to
provide that stability
yes
Andrew Gwen thank you we know that the
prime minister
is now not in power
we know that there has been a coup
because the Prime Minister should be
here to defend her decisions today we
want to know from the Prime Minister why
her economic plan has been trashed just
weeks after it was announced we want to
know from her
whether she is sorry for the misery she
has caused to millions of people across
this country we want to know on behalf
of those who now have new mortgages at
higher interest rates for the
foreseeable future whether she's sorry
for her actions the Prime Minister she
says isn't carrying away
[Applause]
so if if she isn't carrying away will
she be here to sit by the chancellor and
to show her confidence in the new plans
to the country
I know it is uh not usually in the
nature of the honorable gentleman to
overly dramatize the situation
I do what I do agree with with what he
said is this is a serious these are
serious matters for our constituents and
uh I hope that all honorable members
will be able to question the chancellor
and get answers they need for their
constituents John Mayer Mr Speaker
fiscal credibility is always at the
backbone of any growth policy so I
welcome the actions of the chance with
its Checker but just as important are
pro-growth reforms to back entrepreneurs
and businesses so can the leader of the
House confirm to me that the government
will continue to review EU inspired
regulations to make them bespoke for the
UK economy deliver pro-growth investment
zones right across the country and Blue
Star Energy Supply yeah I can give my
honorable friend that that insurance
this is this is really important to our
communities we will continue with our
program of uh on EU law and EU retained
law uh also on our
enabling regulation the department for
trade is looking looking at and also on
investment zones which there has been an
enormous number of expressions of
Interest bill esterson in her initial
answer to the Urgent question the leader
of the House blamed International
circumstances but if that's true why is
it that people in this country face
paying more in their increases in
mortgage payments than elsewhere in the
world
and if it's true why did the former
deputy governor of the bank of England
say yesterday
that they crash in the markets
is the result of unique circumstances in
the UK wouldn't it be better for her and
for the prime minister to admit that
they got it wrong that they are
responsible as a first unnecessary step
in rebuilding confidence in the markets
well I would Point The Honorable
gentleman to mortgage rates uh elsewhere
in the world but also uh suggests he
raises this with the chancellor who is
waiting to give a statement Dr Karen
Mill thank you Mr Speaker I welcome the
the change of approach and I think it
was a the right thing to take in the
circumstances at times like this our
constituents still do want to be
reassuring reassured they're worried
about their bills can you confirm for
our constituents in the whole house that
our plan to help people with their bills
this winter remains in place
I I can give him that Assurance
um the the chancellor statement today is
in is incredibly important and people
will want to hear about the package that
we're bringing forward to help on Energy
prices but also other measures as well
to help with cost of living yeah
thank you very much Mr Speaker we've
just seen the back of one Tory prime
minister for trampling over standards in
public life only for them to be replaced
by another who in just 40 days has
herself failed to meet at least three of
the Nolan principals I'd love to ask the
Prime Minister herself about it but
given that she's not here I asked the
leaders of the house is it leadership to
sack your Chancellor for doing exactly
what he was asked to do is it
objectivity to refuse to allow the obr
experts to assess the so-called mini
budget and does she agree that the first
test of accountability is to actually
show up
leave the house it I would suggest to
her that it is leadership to take tough
decisions in the National interest even
though there may be personally and
politically difficult to take
Mr Speaker the party opposite stood on a
Manifesto that would have inflicted
on my constituency
that labor can never be trusted support
the hard-working people of the UK or
south and west
The Honorable lady is not wrong
Rebecca longberry
speaker Pendleton Leisure Center a
flagship Council development to tackle
Health inequalities in an area of high
deprivation which seldom enjoys such
investment we suspended last week
largely I'm told as a result of the
government's economic car crash and the
prospect of more public spending cuts to
come with the leader of the House
apologize on behalf of the Prime
Minister to the people of Salford
yeah later well this is uh although this
is not business questions if the
honorable lady would like to give me the
details of that case I'd be happy to
take it up Simon bench
can my right honorable friend assure the
house and my constituents included South
that this government will always pay its
way and make whatever tough decisions
are necessary to ensure that we go for
growth in a responsible and conservative
way say that I can give him that
assurance and the chancellor will be
along shortly to give him some more
details Stephen Flynn Mr Speaker can I
ask the leader of the House who does she
consider does a U-turn better the prime
minister or the leader of the Scottish
tories
[Applause]
that The Honorable gentleman in his
party might do a U-turn and decide to
honor the Democratic voter in the
referendum
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker since being elected
I've spent three years working on the
health select committee with the now
Chancellor he's got an eye for detail of
compassion as well isn't he exactly the
right person to come forward and
stabilize and demonstrate to the markets
how difficult it can be in turbulent
times but he is the man to bring us
forward
those remarks about the new Chancellor I
think that is precisely why the Prime
Minister has chosen him Dave diamond
thank you Mr Speaker in terms of the
national interest and also to offer
further reassurance to the markets can
the leader of the house just confirm
that the Prime Minister will not be
taking any decisions on economic policy
in the future
[Laughter]
okay yeah
I hope
I
have
I have great affection for the uh for
the honorable lady and uh I'm sure that
whole house appreciates her question but
um the Prime Minister and her Chancellor
and her cabinet will be taking these
decisions in the future and the decision
that she has taken over the weekend
although personally difficult for her is
the right one for the nation Sarah Owen
speaker the leader of the house has
mentioned a couple of times now that the
Prime Minister has taken difficult
decisions can I please enlighten her
that these are not difficult decisions
difficult decisions are what are facing
our constituents choosing whether they
can actually turn the lights on finding
out how they can heat their homes and
how they can feed their children don't
our constituents and those people
deserve the answer from our prime
minister and not an answer about to say
our Chancellor will come and tell us
later
well the The Honorable lady uh will want
to hear from the chancellor because she
will be able to ask him the precise
questions uh that are of interest to her
constituents this government has always
protected people against the cost of
living and it has always protected the
most vulnerable in our society and we
will continue to do that well they
should come Michael Mr Speaker can I say
to the leader of the house that she and
her colleagues do not have a monopoly on
the understanding of what it is to take
difficult decisions in the National
interest in 2010 my colleagues and I
entered government and took many
difficult decisions for which we paid a
political price we did that because it
was in the National interest we did it
on the advice of the bank of England and
we set up the office of budget
responsibility as a consequence the
Prime Minister would also be part of
that government at what point did she
think it was no longer necessary to
listen to the bank of England and the
OVR
that's when I first thanked the right
honor gentleman for uh raising the
issues we faced in 2010 when we came in
people will remember the notes uh
outlining there was no money left what
is less well understood is the scorched
Earth policy that accompanied it to tie
an incoming government into all kinds of
contractual difficulties to make their
job so much harder that is why those on
the opposition benches should never be
allowed near government and I would say
to The Honorable gentleman that the
chancellor will be along shortly to
answer questions about the obr just for
Loops thank you Mr Speaker I find it
absolutely incredible that the leader of
the house is incredulous that people
might want to hear from the Prime
Minister as if it's like oh a political
game to us the leader of our country
questions it is an embarrassing thing to
assert but in the National interest and
she so wants to hear from the chancellor
can I ask her to be completely honest
because nothing that we've seen has been
honest
um to oh I apologize
[Applause]
it's not of an individual it's
withdrawal right Carol oh yeah
okay
um good home uh can I ask her why is it
because we had to have the statement
earlier at 11 o'clock while I was on the
train
when you can actually get on a train can
I ask her
can I ask her why the markets needed
reassuring
[Music]
well the first thing I would say to the
The Honorable lady is I I fully
appreciate uh the Optics of me appearing
at the dispatch box and but there is a
very genuine reason why the prime
minister is not here today and I would
just stress to you that uh it is not I
can understand people wishing to make
political hey over it uh she would wish
to be here but she is not able to at
this moment
and the chancellor will be along shortly
to answer these questions
thank you Mr Speaker last Friday the
pound the value of the pound fell after
the Prime Minister walked out after just
over eight minutes from her press
conference isn't it increasingly the
case that she and her government are a
risk to Britain's Financial stability
and isn't it time she stopped shirking
turned out to be held accountable or get
out of the way and call a general
election
I would just stress again to uh all
honorable colleagues that there is a
very good reason why the prime
minister's not here
um and that the chancellor will be
making a statement shortly where you can
ask him these questions David London
everybody on the subject of the
replacement of the chancellor given that
he lasted 30 days in office and crashed
the economy can the leader of the House
confirm that the White Album member for
spill Forum the former Chancellor will
be rejecting his minister of yourself
I would not be involved in uh in that
decision at all um but the honorable
member will know who he can write to to
find that out Ben Bradshaw
she has claimed repeatedly that the
Prime Minister has been courageous but
if the Prime Minister were really
courageous he would be here today
wouldn't she if the Prime Minister
cannot or won't come and explain to the
British people the reasons for her
humiliating u-turns and to apologize to
them as she just did from the dispatch
box for the damage the tourism she had
get done to this country and living
standards and businesses what is the
point of her yeah
well I would refer The Honorable
gentleman to the answer I gave a little
while ago about the other prime minister
and and again to the answer I gave a
moment ago about the fact that I
certainly uh regret the uncertainty uh
that has added to already worries about
the very volatile global economic
situation and that is why I'm keen and
happy that we have a statement from the
chancellor today
thank you very much Mr Speaker the Prime
Minister repeatedly declared that she
was working in lockstep with her
Chancellor but then very unceremoniously
dumped her closest political friend at
the earliest possible opportunity in
order to temporarily save her job and
now in the greatest of ironies she has
sent out the very right honorable lady
to speak on her behalf who is very
Desperately Seeking to replace her but
leader of the house I understand that
Downing Street is hosting a reception
this evening is it awake
um I I would say to the The Honorable
gentleman that the motivations for the
Prime Minister taking the decisions that
she has have been about the national
interest
he may not appreciate and I'm not asking
him to uh the courage and the duty that
she felt to do that but that is why she
has done it Chris Stevens
Mr Speaker so I I just want to be clear
can the leader of the House confirm now
that the former chancellor has been
removed by the Prime Minister for acting
on her instructions and can she also
confirm that the Prime Minister
overruled the father Chancellor and the
contents of the financial statement
before it was made because if both
things are true the Prime Minister needs
to resign doesn't she
these are these are not matters for me
he may wish to raise uh Embrace matters
with the chancellor I think what our
constituents want to hear from us today
is about the issues that are affecting
them and that is what the chancellor
will be speaking about whenever he gets
to this chamber Queen David
can you ask the leader of the House on
behalf of the Prime Minister will she
simply say to the people of his country
we are sorry
I have done so twice before in this uq
and I will do so again I know that this
is a an incredibly uncertain time for
families and businesses across the
country uh the events that led up to the
statement that is being made today are
unfortunate and I am pleased that the
Prime Minister has taken decisive action
to stabilize markets and I'm sure that
he will want to question the chancellor
on those details matters I have I have
done and I'm happy to do so again fly
better thank you Mr Speaker we're told
that the prime minister is going to be
coming in here in a moment so during the
chancellor when he makes his statement
to presumably props up El Sid like like
coach neston
but this should have been an opportunity
for the prime ministers to show
leadership
and to apologize to the nation
before the dispatch box in the chamber
of the House of Commons yet she's failed
to do so we've all heard the stories
about our constituents up and down the
country who have had mortgages withdrawn
at the last minute whose lives have been
put on hold because of the Reckless mini
budget that she agreed with her
Chancellor so doesn't the the leader of
the House agree that it is reckless if
the prime minister to not show that
leadership today and be here in this
chamber to be accountable for what she
has done leader I think the Prime
Minister has shown leadership in taking
the tough decision that she has and not
for the first time if our prime minister
when she was foreign secretary had not
shown leadership we would not alongside
European nations be giving the support
to Ukraine that we rightly should be
proud of
thank you very much Mr Speaker the fact
is that the Prime Minister was as
courageous as a leader I said she'd be
here to answering questions this
afternoon the fact that the prime
ministers are willing to come to the
house shows a complete lack of authority
she now has a week before the country
week before Parliament and week before
the markets refusing to face
parliamentary accountability for actions
is not covered this it's a dead election
of Duty there's little house not agree
with me it's time for this it's well
past time for this lame dot prime
minister to go
later the Prime Minister has come to
this house many times and in the
previous role she's held she's come to
this house many times often uh to talk
about very difficult issues there is a
genuine reason honorable members why she
is not here and uh and uh I hope that
she will be able to join the house later
this afternoon
you thank you Mr Speaker I wasn't going
to rise to ask a question but I've been
concerned at some of the answers that
the lead with the house has given if we
are to stabilize the markets and restore
some confidence in the economy we have
to have trust in the strong leadership
of our country and that is the lead of
that role of the Prime Minister she has
said a number of times that there are
good reasons why the prime minister is
not here this afternoon in the interest
of total transparency and in the
interest of proper accountability and to
restore confidence in markets will she
give us those reasons
the right honorable lady and will have
to be content with my assurances I can't
disclose the reasons I have asked if I
can uh I'm I'm being very genuine uh
with the house on this matter I hope
that she'll be able to join us a bit
later on this afternoon but both the
Prime Minister and her Chancellor and
her cabinet are determined and to take
the tough decisions to ensure that we
have stability and confidence going
forward and I hope that the Chancellor's
statement will reassure the right
honorable lady Chris Brown thank you Mr
Speaker to be honest I just thought it
was utterly shabby to sack
the chancellor of the executor for doing
precisely what he'd been told to do
it's like when you sack the staff for
messing up yourself it's not on it's bad
form it's not honorable it's despicable
yeah but what really worries me is that
you can't really govern if you don't
have a mandate you can't govern if you
can't get your budget through this house
because by definition that shows that
the house does not have confidence in
you every honorable government previous
to this at that moment when it's evident
that they couldn't get their budget
through has resigned and allowed a
general election isn't that what should
happen now
um what would I would say to the The
Honorable gentleman is that I think it
is an honorable thing to do to act in
the National interest even if it is
incredibly difficult personally and
politically for someone to do that and
that all members on this side of the
house were elected uh in 2019 as a team
on a Manifesto that we are determined to
deliver
[Music]
The Honorable lady has said many times
that the Prime Minister couldn't come
here for a specific reason at this time
could I ask the leader of the house is
there a reason why the Prime Minister
decided she didn't want to make a
statement to the house because she could
have chosen any time to do that even at
10 pm does the need of the house not
think that we as elected MPS and the
public in this country deserve to hear
from the Prime Minister
there will be many opportunities to hear
from the prime minister in uh some in
the next uh 24 hours but given the
nature of the statement today it is
appropriate that the chancellor delivers
it Brendan O'Hara
under her desk or behind a couch people
rightly view the prime minister's
sacking of the chancellor as a
particularly unedifying Act of
self-preservation given that he was
thrown under the bus for saying exactly
what she asked him to say it would be
like the ventriloquist Ray Allen sacking
Lord Charles for saying the wrong thing
so so will the leader of the House
joined me now and asking the
ventriloquist dummies on her own benches
who demanded that the Scottish
government follow this insane economy
wrecking policy to apologize to the
people of Scotland
um well the first thing I would say is
to thank him for um the fact that the
public might be concerned for the uh the
former uh Chancellor but I think what
they are really going to be concerned
about is their own household budgets uh
and their businesses and that is why it
is important this decision was taken and
we will hear from the chancellor shortly
um and I um with regard to it as other
point uh I would uh just point out that
there are many people including uh many
people in Scotland who would like the
first minister to apologize for uh the
sum of her decisions thank you
Chris Jim wait thank you Mr Speaker with
her economic plan much like a judgment
in tatters the fact she can't even be
bothered to come to the chamber today
what is the point of prime minister
um
I uh well I thank the The Honorable
gentleman for that uh that insightful
question
I repeat the the Prime Minister I would
normally be here um but there is a good
reason why she isn't
Nick Smith thank you Mr Speaker
is it true that the member for
spellthorne first found out that he was
sacked on Twitter rather than being told
to his face
honorable members of this house are in
obviously
want to ask all kinds of questions but I
think what the public are worried about
is that the cost of living issues the
stability of the markets
the energy package that we would be
putting through later today to help them
with the cost of living and I would just
I would just urge all colleagues to
remember the context in which uh we are
meeting this afternoon Stephanie Pico is
the prime minister on the way to the
Palace
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I would very much like to be able to
tell all honorable colleagues what the
prime minister's business is today but
there are very serious matters as well
as economic matters that are in the
prime minister's in tray and uh she as
as people will know she comes this house
on a regular basis and she'll be here
tomorrow but she's not able to be here
at this precise moment it'll be perfect
the markets were spooked not just by The
Reckless mini budget but also by the
sense that we had a prime minister
incapable of answering questions at the
end of a press conference and without
any sort of grip on this government so
it is entirely legitimate for my writing
bull friend from Holborn Saint Francis
to give her an opportunity to come and
assure the markets isn't the reality
that the prime minister's inability to
answer questions is just as fundamental
as the failure on policy in why this
country is now in an economic crisis
made up by the fact that uh the uh the
members on the opposition benches very
much want to see the Prime Minister and
I hope that if she is able to join us
this afternoon at noon um that they will
give her a big cheer when she does
Christine jaldi
thank you thank you very much Mr Mr
Speaker
I accept
um what the race honorable lady is
saying about the Prime Minister not
being here that there may be a very good
reason and I also agree with her when
she said frequently that
um we must be acting at the moment in
the National interest
for me the national interest is what is
in the interest of our people our
constituents and what they are telling
me in Edinburgh West and I'm sure very
many of the rest of you is that they no
longer have any confidence in this prime
minister
the whale she may have had the courage
to sack her partner in presenting the
growth plan to the country that what
they would like is for her now to have
the courage to accept that she was also
wrong and to step down so will the right
honorable lady under cabinet colleagues
please take that message back to the
Prime Minister wherever she is
look at the house well I think that the
prime minister in her current role and
previous roles has always has always
acted in the National interest and she
will continue to do so her government
will continue to support her what we
need if this country needs some
stability and some Assurance now and she
she always takes decisions in the
National interest Davis
speaker as the new chancellor has
reversed all the economic promises made
by the prime minister in her election
campaign to become Prime Minister and
that very Chancellor had the fewest
votes in that leadership election he was
thrown out with 18. doesn't this show
that the next prime minister should not
be chosen by the members opposite and
their wider membership but by the
British people in a general election as
soon as possible to get this country
back on track
well I think there are serious questions
that we should be examining as a
parliament today and I hope that we will
soon move on to the Chancellor's
statement I think that is what our
constituents are concerned and worried
about and not about events within the
Westminster bubble that Western Mr
Speaker obviously this is an absolute
legitimate question that's been put
forward today the public wants to know
why the Prime Minister sacked her
Chancellor after just 38 days and
particularly given that she was
co-architect of the plans the economic
plans why she herself has not resigned
yeah
tomorrow I think we are having um later
in the week we are having prime
minister's questions uh members have an
opportunity every week to put questions
to the Prime Minister Gibson thank you
Mr Speaker the poem has fallen off a
cliff interest rates of soaring
inflation is rocketing and pensions have
been on the verge of collapse we have a
new Chancellor
who has the deaf Act of prime minister
and the Prime Minister who has been
reduced to a spectator as the only MPS
plot heart removal The Honorable leader
today the leader of the house has
defended the Prime Minister today but
can I ask her does she think if she had
won the leadership contest she would
have been a better prime minister
been in the house
I support the Prime Minister the supply
Minister has has shown great courage and
Duty
she has my admiration and respect for
that The Honorable lady has various
criticisms of her I would stand our
prime minister against her first
Minister any day of the week
thank you Mr Speaker local public
services in Warrington have been slashed
the pieces over the last 12 years and we
are finding it increasingly difficult to
meet the demand for basic statutory
Services let alone before inflation
started rocketing pushing costs of
delivery up any more Cuts will mean
collapse the Prime Minister spent last
week promising no cuts to public
spending and boasting about her two-year
energy price freeze so does she have any
say at all on government economic policy
look at the house well The Honorable
lady can put her questions to the
chancellor uh shortly but what I would
point out is that uh clearly all
organizations are facing Rising costs
that is in part why we have acted so
swiftly and even today uh we'll be
putting through legislation to help with
the business and cost of living
Tom thank you Mr Speaker
the Prime Minister has been in office
for six weeks but notoriously uh even
with the rigors of the budget is yet to
find time to call the first minister of
Scotland or the first minister of Wales
there's a leader of the House think that
the Prime Minister will remain in office
long enough to be able to do so
I know the Prime Minister takes our
responsibilities
I know that the Prime Minister takes her
responsibilities to working
constructively uh with the other
administrations and she will always do
that
Justin mothers thank you Mr Speaker I'm
sure the markets will be reassured to
see the prime ministers not hiding under
a desk but is here in the house today
and she's still got till 10 o'clock
tonight to answer questions that have
been asked if she wants to reassure the
markets and create some stability but
I've got another question for the leader
of the house I've been drawn in prime
minister's questions on Wednesday and
she guarantee that the current prime
minister will be answering them
yes Chris too thank you Mr Speaker
throwing your Chancellor under the bus
in order to save his skin is not a tough
decision tough decisions are when you
make them and then come along show True
leadership and ask people to come with
you by inspiring them this prime
minister has done none of that so why
should we follow her when she's shown no
leadership whatsoever but is hidden away
through the house I think that if you
spoke to any member of the Ukrainian
Parliament they would tell you that our
prime minister
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker
urgent business we are told by the
leader prevented the Prime Minister for
coming to the house what on Earth could
have been more urgent than coming to
atone for the economic chaos that she
has wrought on pension holders and
mortgage payers across these islands and
especially in Scotland with a party
officer enjoying no mandate whatsoever
the Prime Minister thanked her former
Chancellor for the excellent work that
he had done can the leader of the House
explain or maybe now the prime
minister's turned up she can can the
leader house explain thanked for what
The Honorable gentleman will know that
the Prime Minister has prime minister's
questions uh every single week he can
put questions to her there there was
very good reason as I have repeatedly
explained to the house why she could be
here you'll notice that she is present
here now and I will start listening to
The Honorable Gentleman on Democratic
mandates when he honors the results of
the Scottish referendum
thank you very uh Mr speaker thank the
leader of the house for her answers but
I'm not in the business of Point scoring
does the leader of the house not agree
that the face behind the budget is much
less important than what the budget
outlines is there confidence that the
chancellor can help business help people
stay in work ensure that funding is
available for the NHS and government
departments cannot take further
austerity so that all the United Kingdom
of Great Britain and Northern Ireland
can truly be better together
well The Honorable gentleman is held in
great affection by all members of this
house and is often the finale at uh such
uh uqs because he is full of common
sense and I think that what he says is
absolutely right and I hope now we will
be able to hear from the chancellor
[Applause]
to border
is it is it relevant to the questions
[Applause]
border if it's relevant to this I would
say at the point of order Chris Brown
I'm grateful Mr Speaker on a point of
order you know that for the last hour
we've been listening to questions about
which were meant to be directed to the
Prime Minister the leader of the House
said repeatedly that there were reasons
that the Prime Minister could couldn't
be here if there were legitimate Reasons
I'm sure every single member of this
house would want
to hear them now that the Prime Minister
has arrived would this not be a perfect
opportunity for her to be able to
explain why she was not able to work
or just to say and let's just put this
to bed it's not for me it's for the
government to put forward the ministers
to respond to Urgent questions once
granted and it's not a matter for the
church there are members put the point
on the record and I know that the prime
minister is nowhere no place but we now
come before I call the chancellor to
make his stick
I expect better I want you to be silent
while I read this so this is very
important before I call the chancellor
to make a statement I'd like
yes and I think so it's a few times
today and that that's the third apology
I don't want anymore
before I call the chancellor to make
history I'd like to point out that
British sign language interpretation of
proceedings is available to watch on
Parliament live TV so I had no call the
chancellor of the exchequer
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
the central responsibility of any
government is to do what is necessary
for economic stability
behind the decisions we take and the
issues on which we vote
our jobs found